è la tutti i ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video io sono pari j
oggi siamo già più di stato che domenica
ragazzi scusatemi se la scorsa domenica
non ho fatto uscire l'episodio di happy
days ma non c'ero scusatemi quindi direi
di iniziare di iniziare subito il prima
possibile senza fare premesse così
almeno mi recupero tutti i minuti persi
se riesco la vediamo se riusciamo
iniziare così extreme fly chicca caso
vai così con è di cosa sta facendo è di
cioè io non ti lascio solo una settimana
è il tuo perdi la testa va bene ragazzi
e questo è un po strano
devo saltare che cazzo devo fare piva
abita vento poi è di così presto
è una posizione kamasutra con nonno ciak
molto sexy slow motion matrix questo lo
devo fare ragazzi questo devo farlo
assolutamente merda aiuto ragazzi voi
così che figo
ok no non è esattamente così che non mi
ricordavo che matrix andasse così ormai
va da madonna che questa è stata la c'è
allora ragazzi james bond mi fa una
pippa c'è sono riuscito a uccidere steve
tirando un calcio in rovesciata un
missile c'è una cosa che non vedrete mai
neanche nei migliori film d'azione can
you win 100 mi stai chiedendo se io
posso vincere
a chiederli pensa che io non possa
farcela lui me lo sta chiedendo
cioè lui non sa ancora con piatti e fare
cioè confavi j assicuro che si vince
bene allora cosa stoffa no è no è di
cosa fare e ho vinto ho vinto ho vinto
solo col corso cioè ragazzi questa non
me lo so spiegare neanch'io mega jump
viste cos'è questo mi ispira dallo zio
oddio devo premere z credo devo
staccarmi cioè mi sono staccato ho preso
la salsiccia no la salsiccia era mia mi
è rimasto solo del cibo per cani perché
mi accontenterò di questo è così cibo
borgo maniche buono vai così a lo mangio
come i cani maledizione sé perché sono
sexy ragazzi questa è una cosa molto
oscena dovete lo sta infilando quel
cazzo acrobazie col cibo per cani
bene ma questo lo devo rifare perché mi
sembra epico ama si può spie ditelo che
ne so io
va bene allora sono senza gambe ho preso
una scatola di cereali una scatola di
cereali esperti può tornar benissimo
ragazzi questo è un botto run per
esperti cioè per fa vj bene gli occhi e
partito cosa stai facendo gli fai scuse
sconce con tuo padre
devo riuscire ma dai che sono quasi ma
da non ci posso credere vaio fai vedere
chi sei fai vedere chi sei no group armi
da dietro maledetto pervertito vai
avanti se ragazzi devo riuscirci
assolutamente vai vai vai vai gli hawks
spingi cos'è grandissimo luke fantastico
questa è stato tutto merito tuo che hai
fatto da motore dietro bene il prossimo
al level ragazzi facciamo soltanto
questo perché voglio soltanto far capire
al creatore di questo livello dove steve
che non lo vedo pilota eccolo non lo
trovavo bene vai si fa vedere che cosa
fai sti break e ti sei fatto trafiggere
la prostata steve perché poi steve vai
così non ci credo ma dai ma com'è fatta
morire così se vai così steve ci siamo
fatti riconoscere un altra volta fa
alcune lerro grande raga questo lo devo
fare assolutamente perché mi sento ok
quei ragazzi preparate che qualcosa di
epico senza vedere
voglio che cazzo parte era capelli
quando ride o magari già morto ho
sentito un urlo quindi sono già morto
come sono morto non lo so bene
allora meglio se guardo la cosa non so
che faccio bene va agli occhi basti
vedere chi sei
be nice
sì in effetti se guardo vinco perché se
non guardo non so neanche dove vado
source
cos'è sto shooting questo mi ispira non
so come bayern o dio
cos'è ma nomadi devo prendere la palla
forse magari devo prenderla no è
difficile madonna vajasse bomber è di il
capocannoniere di serie a fantastico la
stryker cento ways to die epic col trova
deejay radio a questo è un livello
delicato a me lo faccio
ok grazie mille ragazzi allora il primo
è fa vj cosa cosa succede se prendo fa
ejei lux punto io nel gioco poi vigetti
voi ragazzi questo non ha senso però
grazie c'è il mio avatar apparso in alto
fantastico bene posso farcela
replay cosa la riprendo riprendo la
palla che è successo bene ragazzi ce la
fa allora la vittoria e licia posso fare
mai così meteo la meteora spero non mi
ammazzi maledizione devo vincere prima
che mi arrivi l'avete ferma bastardi non
c'è verso
allora devo vincere stato tra vittoria
c'è lo star di no ok no no no no muori
oggi non morirò oggi [ __ ] e così
ricche mario non mi ammazza rete anche
oggi non mi ammazza rete è di bilancio
manco goku la strapotenza vai col genchi
dama madonna è di sei un ribelle caso
sei troppo figo madonna cosa sto facendo
oddio dio dio dio dio ok calmi ragazzi
sta succedendo l'impensabile è così edy
morì soffocato perfetto ragazzi ce la
posso fare
la vittoria non è così lontani così
lontana ma porca [ __ ] non c'è verso
devo riuscire si quante palle prendo mio
dio
no no no no no no ok non mi interessa se
non stufa vj la merda
ragazzi è impossibile allora i miei
livelli è risaputo che io non riesco a
finirli perché sono impossibili non so
perché cos'è quello cos'è cosa si sa
cos'è che stavo disegno poiché secondo
facili livelli non riesco a farli come
non detto perfetto ragazzi ce l'ho fatta
non so neanche come fa ce l'ho fatta va
bene così
rainbow rob swing questo devo fare ecco
no con da quando non c'è fire of swing
va beh almeno è figo posso
permetterglielo magari se parti bene by
dono ciak puoi vedere che anche tu una
volta di come è di mio zio è tornato
anche indietro lui è un atleta fa
vincere le montagne ragazzi voglio
provare a fare dei livelli fatti faccia
parigi qui dalle montagne russe va bene
non sono un grande esperto ma ciò che
più di me
ciao favi questo primo livello di 18
attacco le montagne russe
no cazzo l'anno jack dove vai perché
allora va bene sta lui va bene
raga e non posso frenare ce l'ha scritto
frena ma non posso frenare perché come
puoi vedere mi è partita mi è partito il
calo è bene ho vinto ho mio zio non si
posso credere.ho ragazzi questa è stata
la cosa più epica io ho vinto senza
neanche seguire il tragitto cioè ho
fatto un salto all'inizio è stato epico
ragazzi questa è stata una cosa
fantastica bene queste sono le montagne
russe secondo po vj benissimo imposti
col per famiglie va bene ragazzi
stavolta sono carico sì però siamo tutti
calmi kaliso mi devo concentrare ok
ragazzi mimì mi dispiace che c'è ancora
gente che dubita che io non sia pavi già
in perfetto se un partito malissimo
steve steve devi ok perfetto non
stupirti da solo steve bene ok ok è
ovvio
cos'era sta roba non era una mossa nuova
oddio magari vinco calcio se tutto va
bene perché devo guardare una cosa epica
va bene ragazzi maledizione ce l'ha
quasi
in effetti i miei livelli perché i miei
livelli sono i birrifici ragazzi potete
farli più facili la bene noi non li
voglio più facili voglio più difficile
ancora la prossima volta perché questo
non è nulla bene ok c'ero ma porca
allora non è possibile non è possibile
maledizione ho capito ho capito capito
capito subito 6
[Musica]
avevate dei dubbi adesso non più
benissimo ragazzi è il posti
l'impossibile andato che ne faccio un
altro va bene perché magari la solo
fortuna per farvi capire che non era
solo fortuna farfa vj miglior youtuber
grazie mille e vabbè ma questo
scusate devo farlo è una cosa un po
strana ma dovrei riuscire a vincere
salgado di testa ok va bene ragazzi
abbiamo capito che non c'è verso se
provate a sfidarmi con un possible perde
a prescindere perché non ci siamo
imposti voi che non so fare livello per
far vincere in perfetto stavolta vado
col padre di hugh livello proprio i j
baia shulman ok devo arrivare alla fine
non ci posso credere sono morto alla
fine non deve riuscirci devo riuscirci
assolutamente assolutamente
bene bene non avevo dubbi ragazzi perché
avevate dubbi poiché non ci riuscissi
siete degli infedeli world lauper fa vj
ragazzi ancora di scontro oggi non ho
fatti one certo che il dal bel ricordo
dai beach hockey e steve è andato dove
uscire a prendere sei andato anche nonno
chuck non mi chiedete come mai ho vinto
solo fatto nulla ma ho vinto va bene
così raga vige lo chiamo vedere che cosa
creata è fantastico e farisei al vento
spesso mi ispira al nome sarà fantastico
lo so by giulia class piper pa vigenti
grazie mille giulia dal club questo
splendido livello per me ma non pensare
che io muoia
ok presso azienda mai con z bene ce la
posso fare
qual è detto vicino maledizione la
vicini tentava di superare ce l'ha fatta
anche va bene ho vinto ho vinto e va
bene questo ok perfetto stava succedendo
di tutto a slow motion tuffa vj perfetto
sarebbe per fa dj ma non importa
solo masson con chuck bene devo devo
prendere l'anguria se ce l'ha fatta
vabbè ma questa non era per me non c'è
scritto nulla tipo per fa vj perfetto
come non detto meglio che vi sto zitto
pizzi per fa vj ragazzi presso devo fare
voglio vedere che cosa avete tirato
fuori stavolta i video sui 30mila
iscritti a casa era riferito charlie
bunny perfetto me lo ricordavo volevo
soltanto vedere se eravate attenti ok
allora devo andare sul chabib anni
perche tre ragazzi voi che la prossima
favi buttati che morbido qualcosa mi
dice che non mi devo fidare non mi
dovevo finale va bene ho finito bene
cos'è lo swing force vige bayan di avg
preferenze la nutella pilat fa vg steve
j
è un rock swing per me è di non mi
deludere mai così può fare ragazzi
perché più grandi youtuber del mondo non
ci riescono a fare questo livello ma io
ce la faccio al primo tentativo
sono sicuro ma inizia mai così greg ce
la posso fare
c'è la posto dove mi devo lasciare
fatemi quando andare lì perfetto altro
giro altra corsa
vai così no grande di con tanto di salto
mortale e non ci posso credere non ci
credo sono morto alla pena spero di
arrivarci lo stesso gip racing don di
euro ok non lo faccio
ok sono almeno vinto col corpo quindi va
bene lo stesso
purtroppo per poi vincere il mio primo
bacio spero che ti piaccia ad eugene
ferite ma che ragazzi ce la posso fare
ce la posso fare vai così da un limite è
do divide non ce la faccio non ce la
faccio no
i ragazzi ho fatto una cosa è mica mi
sono salvato prendendo un'altra morte
dai che ce la posso fare
questo perché la vittoria è bloccata
dalle spade cioè ma tra tutte le cose
che si potranno bloccare proprio la
vittoria c'è ma fatemi capire mai così
no un'altra volta la morte
mi sa che stavolta sono morto davvero
perché non posso più
dai getti genti
[Musica]
e ancora no ragazzi questo è stato un
culo assurdo benissimo avere cacchiano
qui per questo episodio de vito è
piaciuto lasciato commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook che come in
ogni video trovate la descrizione se non
siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
rivediamo in un prossimo vito belle
ragazze